advisors to the fda have unanimously
voted to recommend authorization of the
pfizer and madurona vaccines for kids as
young as six months that's about 18
million kids and as meg oliver reports
it could be a game changer for parents
too
for mothers like laura holm gaining
access to covet shots for the nation's
youngest children will bring a sigh of
relief how frustrating has it been to
have one child who's vaccinated and one
who's not very because the goal posts
have continued to be moved for the
younger kids holmes eight-year-old
charlotte is already vaccinated but she
feels her four-year-old catherine has
been left behind once she's fully
vaccinated maybe we don't have to wear a
mask when we go to church or maybe we
don't have to mask when i run into the
store
not everyone shares her excitement a
recent survey found that just 18 percent
of parents with children under five will
vaccinate their kids when the shots are
authorized 38 plan to wait and see and
27 percent say they will not get their
children vaccinated at all but
pediatrician colleen kraft says shots
for the under five crown are critical
not just to protect them but their
families too it's a much better shot at
decreasing the risk of transmission to
other people and mutation of the virus
for the future
get my function
four-year-old astrid pearson received
the vaccine as part of pfizer's clinical
trials her mother andrea says it's been
life-changing she started doing swim
lessons which has been great she's been
able to come with me to go grocery
shopping she's also gotten to
participate in a ballet with some of her
friends and it's just
really opened the door for her to have a
much
larger enriching experience in life
experts stress that children under five
will need to get all their shots not
just one to be protected from covid
pfizer's vaccine is a three dose regimen
modernist is two the cdc is expected to
follow the fda with a formal
recommendation over the weekend if that
happens shots could be available as
early as next week nate meg thank you